belastungszeuge gegen den präsidenten
eine schlüsselfigur in der ukraine
affäre bringt donald trump vor dem
us-kongress in bedrängnis tödlicher
angriff im krankenhaus der arzt fritz
von weizsäcker sohn des früheren
bundespräsidenten wird bei einem vortrag
erstochen als erster zur em die dfb elf
gewinnt 6 zu 1 gegen nordirland und holt
den gruppensieg in der em quali
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers meine damen und herren
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
heute um 7 sport in diesem
nachrichtenüberblick nachher mit kristin
otto neben fußball auch tenniscourt
wir beginnen mit den ermittlungen zu
einer möglichen amtsenthebung von us
präsident donald trump dort hat ein
wichtiger zeuge den präsidenten heute in
große schwierigkeiten gebracht der
amerikanische botschafter bei der eu
golden sun land ist eine schlüsselfigur
in der ukraine affäre
er sagte heute vor dem us-parlament aus
es habe druck gegeben auf die ukraine
gegen einen politischen kontrahenten von
trump zu ermitteln
und zwar auf anweisung des präsidenten
mehr von elmar theveßen
entlastung für den präsidenten das
hatten sich die republikaner von gordon
sound lenz auftritt erhofft der us
botschafter bei der eu gilt als
vertrauter donald trumps für dessen
amtseinführung er eine million dollar
spendete danach wurde der geschäftsmann
ohne jede diplomatische erfahrung us
botschafter in brüssel
jetzt belastet der trump und seinen
persönlichen anwalt rudy giuliani schwer
die forderungen von giuliani waren ein
quid pro quo giuliani habe als
vorbedingung für einen besuch des
ukrainischen präsidenten im weißen haus
eine öffentliche ankündigung von
ermittlungen verlangen dass die
ermittlungen auch gegen trumps
politischen widersacher joe biden das
sei keine wilde neben diplomatie das
weiße haus das außenministerium alle
hätten gewusst dass giuliani im auftrag
trumps unterwegs war
giuliani handelte auf wunsch des
präsidenten und wir wussten alle dass
dem präsidenten diese ermittlungen
wichtig waren
der demokratische ausschussvorsitzende
fragten nach ob auch die amerikanische
militärhilfe für die ukraine fast 400
millionen dollar an die ermittlungen
geknüpft war
davon war ich überzeugt als spekulation
greifen dass die republikaner an in
einem amtsenthebungsverfahren gehe es
doch um beweise
ich habe klargemacht wo ich etwas nur
vermute wie in diesen präsident trump
schrieb heute mit was sonst land im
kongress auch aus sagte über ein
telefonat zwischen ihm und schon
ich will nichts ich will kein quid pro
quo
sagen sie dem ukrainischen präsidenten
er soll das richtige tun
die aussage sondern hinterlässt wirkung
beim präsidenten el mati wissens hätte
er vor schenkten der eu botschafter hat
seinen präsidenten belastet wie
schwerwiegend ist das denn unterm strich
jetzt für donald trump ja also sondern
hat unter eid ausgesagt wenn er wirklich
die wahrheit spricht dann wäre es so
dass der us-präsident einen teil seiner
ist eingespannt hätte für wahlkampfhilfe
also dagegen seine politischen
widersacher joe biden zu bekommen und
dass er momentan auch verhindert dass
dokumente darüber die dann vorliegen
müssten im weißen haus an den kongress
weitergegeben werden es macht am ende
vielleicht keinen unterschied im
amtsenthebungsverfahren weil es bräuchte
eine 2 bei dem senat also mindestens 20
republikaner die mit stimmen für eine
entfernung aus dem amt aber vielleicht
macht es einen unterschied bei der wahl
die in genau einem jahr in amerika
stattfindet immer vielen dank und wir
bitten die leichten ton aussetzer zu
entschuldigen
wie viel zählt die wahrheit wenn es um
die macht geht das fragen sich gerade
britische wähler
es geht um ein täuschungsmanöver auf
twitter und es geht um boris johnson
die pressestelle des britischen premiers
ergab sich während des tv duells mit
oppositionschef jeremy corbijn gestern
abend als faktenchecks service aus und
gab vor aussagen des rivalen zu
widerlegen irreführung im wahlkampf sagt
wetter eine fernsehdebatte und ihre
folgen andreas stamm würden sie diesem
mann eine waschmaschine abkaufen am tag
nach dem duell hat boris johnson ein
glaubwürdigkeitsproblem in den wahlkampf
alltag hinein verfolgt ihn eine szene
von gestern als die moderatorin fragt
wie wichtig sei ihm die wahrheit
gelächter genau wie im moment als
oppositionsführer corbijn erklärt wie er
die brekzie blockade lösen will
die potenziellen führer des landes
bergen ausgelacht johnsons
glaubwürdigkeitsproblem verstärkt diese
aktion parallel zum duell benennt sich
ein twitter kanal seiner partei in
faktencheck uk um erklärt johnson zum
sieger fake news eine arglistige
wählertäuschung scheint nicht nur die
opposition sich genauso zu nennen wie
ein bekannter unabhängiger faktencheck
skandalös ausgerechnet wenn sich viele
fragen ob man balls johnson vertrauen
kann das duell endet unentschieden so
die kommentatoren was johnson nutzt der
in den umfragen vorne bleiben dürfte
dank seiner bekannten formel mit corbijn
würde es referenten über den eu austritt
und die schottische unabhängigkeit geben
oder wir beenden das nationale elend
regeln in braig cid das fazit des tests
publikums im studio schlecht sitzende
brille gegen schlecht sitzende frisur
wer wütend und ratlos ist soll die hand
heben ein klares ergebnis
großbritannien hat die qual der wahl und
eigentlich gibt es nichts zu lachen denn
der wahlsieger entscheidet über die
zukunftsfrage wie geht es weiter in
sachen braig sind unser nächstes thema
hirntod so hatte der französische
präsident manual makro und die nato
bezeichnet angesichts politischer
alleingänge der usa und der türkei aus
dem minister heiko maas reagiert jetzt
darauf und fordert eine erneuerung
wörtlich politische frischzellen für das
bündnis zum nato treffen mit seinen
amtskollegen in brüssel schlug mars eine
expertenkommission vor
sie soll die nato so reformieren dass
die zusammenarbeit der mitgliedsstaaten
besser wird darüber müsse noch mal kurz
reden mit unserem korrespondenten in
brüssel wunder krüger gründer guten
abend sind wir denn heute einen schritt
weiter was die zukunft der nato angeht
die ja unbestritten probleme hat was
steckt hinter diesem deutschen vorschlag
auf eine fälle steckt dahinter der
versuch frankreich und die usa ganz fest
in diesem bündnis zu erhalten
die nato war ja immer ein militärisches
bündnis aber eben auch ein politisches
und hinter dem wort vom hirntod steckt
ja auch irgendwie der vorwurf die usa
hätten das politische ein wenig
vergessen
diese analyse teilt deutschland durchaus
aber es zieht nicht die gleichen
schlüsse daraus wie frankreich
frankreich möchte dass europa sich
künftig selbst verteidigen kann
deutschland weiß wie viel dafür noch
fehlt heiko maas kam vor gut einer
stunde hier aus der sitzung raus und
sagt er habe viel zustimmung erhalten
von einer zustimmung des us
außenministers mike kompon haben wir
noch nichts gehört gerade in diesen
minuten läuft seine pressekonferenz also
der vorschlag von heiko maas für eine
expertenkommission hat durchaus chancen
und wenn es auch nur die chance ist gut
wetter zu machen für den geburtstag der
nato den sie im dezember in london
feiern wie die analyse aus brüssel an
einem wichtigen tag für die nato nach
vielen dank deutsche innenpolitik jetzt
den brandenburg kann die neue regierung
zweieinhalb monate nach der landtagswahl
loslegen der alte und neue
ministerpräsident heißt dietmar woidke
der spd politiker bekamen im landtag in
potsdam im ersten wahlgang die nötige
mehrheit allerdings mit drei stimmen
weniger als seine koalition aus spd cdu
und grünen zusammen hat anschließend
wurde woidke vereidigt trauer
betroffenheit und neue erkenntnisse nach
dem tödlichen angriff auf den arzt fritz
von weizsäcker
gestern abend hatte der sohn des
früheren bundespräsidenten richard von
weizsäcker in einer berliner klinik
einen vortrag gehalten als ein zuschauer
auf ihn losgeht und ihnen ersticht ein
57 jähriger deutscher wurde festgenommen
markus groß berichtet noch am tatort
nimmt die polizei den mutmaßlichen täter
fest es ist ein 57 jähriger deutscher
aus rheinland pfalz der kurz zuvor fritz
von weizsäcker chefarzt in der
schlosspark klinik mit einem messer
getötet haben soll
nach ersten erkenntnissen sollen
psychisch krank sein
es gibt keine persönliche beziehung
zwischen dem beschuldigten und dem
getöteten motiv für die tat soll
vielmehr eine allgemeine abneigung gegen
die familie des getöteten seien von
einer tat im wahn sprechen die ermittler
er wird noch heute in eine
psychiatrische klinik gebracht
gestern abend 19 uhr der mediziner von
weizsäcker hält einen öffentlichen
vortrag sein thema volkskrankheit
fettleber plötzlich rennt der angreifer
auf ihn zu stich die nina trotz
sofortiger hilfe stirbt der 59 jährige
arzt noch an ort und stelle ein polizist
der nicht im dienst war will helfen und
wird selbst schwer verletzt im
krankenhaus hat die klinikleitung am
nachmittag ein kondolenzbuch ausgelegt
für patienten und mitarbeiter
der schock sitzt tief fassungslos mir
tut es wahnsinnig leid ich kann es kaum
fassen und es ist sehr tragisch umd ich
weiß noch gar nicht wie ich heute
arbeiten für betroffene bietet die
schlosspark klinik psychologische hilfe
an um das trauma der nacht zu bewältigen
unser nächstes thema und eine brisante
frage jetzt was passiert mit den
mitgliedern der termin ics im türkisch
syrischen grenzgebiet zumal dort ja
jetzt türkische russische und syrische
armee patrouillieren und die bisherigen
bewacher die kurden immer mehr unter
druck geraten
katrin eigendorf hat als erste deutsche
journalistin in einem gefängnis in der
nähe von al hassaka gefilmt dort halten
kurdische einheiten 5000 ehemaliges
kämpfer in schach wenige kilometer
außerhalb der von der türkei
beanspruchten sogenannten
sicherheitszone eine ehemalige
berufsschule im norden syriens
provisorisch umgebaut zu einem gefängnis
nur für männer
syrer iraker europäer auf engstem raum
zusammengepfercht in diesem gefängnis
dessen ort geheim gehalten wird werden
mehr als 5000 extrem gefährliche diaz
anhänger gefangen gehalten
die kurden sagen uns dass sie damit
völlig überfordert sind und fordern dass
die internationale gemeinschaft hier
eingreift und sie unterstützt vor mit
dem er ist einer von fünf deutschen
gefangenen wie alle hier streitet er ab
an gräueltaten beteiligt gewesen zu sein
distanzieren vom es will er sich nicht
der grundprinzip des islams staates hat
gestimmt der grundprinzip dass man nun
mit dem gesetz herrschen darf hat
gestimmt deswegen bin ich hingegangen
deswegen köpfen oder wegen gegen andere
sachen das war mir zu dem zeitpunkt so
sagen recht egal radio-talkshow wurde
als kämpfer des gs verletzt
er fordert jetzt in deutschland vor
gericht gestellt zu werden ich recht
nämlich mit lebenslänglich oder so
einige jahre durch würde ich ja auch
kein problem und würde ich verstehen
wenn auch verständlich wie möglich einen
großen fehler gedanken über den möglich
büro jeden diesen fehler dass die
gefangenen bei dieser unzureichenden
überwachung ausbrechen könnten
darin sehen die kurden eine reale gefahr
nicht nur für syrien sondern auch für
europa der sogenannte islamische staat
könnte sich eines tages neu formieren
und eine lange reportage zu diesem thema
von katrin eigendorf sehen sie heute
abend im auslandsjournal um 22.45 hier
im zdf europaweit entsetzen hat vor zwei
jahren der mord an der journalistin
daphne caro anna galizia ausgelöst die
bloggerin aus malta hatte ein
korruptionsskandal recherchiert bei dem
spuren bis in höchste regierungskreise
führten
jetzt hat malta das militär einen
einflussreichen geschäftsmann
festgenommen der im verdacht steht als
drahtzieher den mordauftrag erteilt zu
haben
die einheiten stoppten ihn auf dieser
yacht als er gerade einen hafen auf
malta verlassen wollte die journalistin
lebt nicht mehr ihre arbeit wirkt weiter
und jetzt in venedig dieser
einzigartigen stadt werden nach dem
hochwasser die schäden sichtbar
verheerend vor allem am weltkulturerbe
ein meter 87 stand das wasser höher als
normal dass die gebäude im wasser stehen
in venedig nichts neues aber wenn wasser
in die gebäude läuft die mauern also
auch noch von innen nass werden dann hat
das schwere folgen
annette hilsenbeck berichtet auch wenn
noch zu sehen ist wie hoch die
rekordflut stand letzte woche
es ist normalität eingekehrt in venedig
doch architekt giovanni de la costa weiß
das ist trügerisch
es war ein dramatisches ereignis das die
sowieso bestehenden probleme in venedig
verschärft denn die fluten erreichten
auch stadtviertel die sonst vom
hochwasser verschont sind zeigt der
pegel mehr als 140 zentimeter gilt stufe
rot sind knapp zwei drittel der stadt
betroffen
jetzt war es fast die ganze stadt das
wasser drang in palazzi kirchen und
häuser ein die sonst trocken blieben
man kann sich vorstellen wie
zerstörerisch es ist wenn zum beispiel
50 zentimeter wasser über eine zwei
stunden in kontakt mit oberflächen im
inneren sind die auch noch verziert sagt
in der kirche von sunways sonst selten
vom aqua alta heimgesucht stand das
wasser so hoch
nicht nur die kostbaren in asien sind
betroffen auch die wände die von innen
das salzige nass aufsaugen
eine zerstörerische kraft die sich in
gemäuern über monate entfaltet ihr seht
ihr spuren von salz das salz bleibt in
dem gemäuer wenn es trocknet das wasser
weg ist dort kristallisiert es aus und
springt zerstört das material venedig
räumt jetzt aufwirft vom flutwasser
zerstörtes weg die großen schäden aber
werden erst mit der zeit sichtbar werden
albtraumhafte bilder aus einer
traumstadt
und jetzt der sport christi genau ich
hab was schönes erst fußball 6 1 gegen
nordirland gruppen-erster ziel erreicht
die deutsche nationalmannschaft im
aufwind wohl wissend dass alle drei
wm-gruppenspiele kommenden juni mit
heimvorteil in münchen ausgetragen
werden also die grundstimmung ist
äußerst positiv
überzeugende leistung am ende eines
schwierigen länderspiel
jahres in dem sie zur symbolfigur des um
groß aufgestiegen ist im verjüngten team
verkörpert der dreifache torschütze alle
qualitäten die einen top-stürmer
ausmachen
die gegner bei der em allerdings werden
eine ganz andere klasse haben als
nordirland dennoch eine gelungene tor
party von gabri der nun auf 13 treffer
in 13 einsätzen kommt das ergebnis denke
ich ja lasst uns gute laune haben und ja
ein schöner abschluss des jahres und
eine gute leistung bestätigt im
gegensatz zur defensive macht die
offensive mut für die em gibt natürlich
auch selbstbewusstsein gibt den spielern
auch das gefühl wenn man gewisse abläufe
macht dass sie dann auch erfolgreich
sind und daher denke ich kann zufrieden
jetzt halt die winterpause gehen
im nächsten jahr müssen aber weitere
entwicklungsschritte folgen um wieder
zur europäischen elite zu zählen und zum
tennis gelungener auftakt für die
deutsche mannschaft in die neue davis
cup endrunde im ersten gruppenspiel
besiegte das team das ohne seinen besten
alexander zverev in madrid antreten muss
argentinien
nachdem philipp kohlschreiber im ersten
einzel gegen guido pa in drei sätzen
rang sicherte jan lennard struff im
spitzenduell gegen diego schwarzmann mit
einem zweisatzerfolg den entscheidenden
zweiten punkt auch zur freude von boris
becker dem chef des deutschen
herrentennis und das doppel läuft noch
morgen geht es gegen chile weiter
christi vielen dank jetzt noch bilder
bei denen wir schwanken zwischen mitleid
und erleichterung es geht um lewis
kleiner koalabär für den diese
australierin buchstäblich ihr letztes
hemd gegeben hat sie hat ihn gerettet
aus den tödlichen flammen die in
australien seit wochen wüten
jetzt sehen sich die zwei wieder im
koala krankenhaus hier wird lewis gerade
aufgepäppelt er sieht noch ziemlich
mitgenommen aus aber er ist auf dem weg
der besserung und jedem dort
und hier fällt ein stein vom herzen
die lottozahlen die gewinnzahlen lauten
27 10 18 31 42 und die superzahl 0
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 55 7
katja horneffer hat gleich nicht nur
sonne und nebel sondern auch regen im
angebot also irgendwie alles heute
journal mit dem kollegen claus kleber um
22 uhr 15 heute danke ihnen allen für
heute gerne ist morgen machen sie sich
einen angenehm haben
[Musik]
meine damen und herren die tage werden
immer kürzer und die sonne hat immer
weniger zeit den nebel aufzulösen heute
aber klappte das sie im westen zum teil
recht gut und auch über frankreich jetzt
kommt ein neues tieferes tief theke und
das bringt schon den ersten regen in der
nacht an die untere donau der regen von
heute zieht hier in norddeutschland aus
deutschland raus sonst bemüht sich zum
teil wieder dicker nehmen und es kann
auch glatt seien auf den straßen denn
die temperaturen sinken doch verbreitet
auf plus 3 bis minus 3 grad und nur im
osten ist es bei vier oder fünf grad
etwas milder
und auch dort erwarten wir morgen die
höchsten temperaturen bis zu zehn grad
erwarten wir zwischen der lausitz und
der ostseeküste sonst steigen die
temperaturen auf fünf bis acht grad und
das wird für die meisten ein eher trüber
donnerstag mit dem tief theke bringt
immer wieder etwas regen oder
nieselregen im westen ist es etwas
freundlicher und am nachmittag hatte es
zwischen dem schwarzwald und im allgäu
sogar richtig sonnig sein
der winter zu kommt meist aus östlichen
bis südöstlichen richtungen
das bleibt auch in den nächsten tagen
somit viel unterstützung kann es am
samstag für bis zu 14 grad am alpenrand
reichen schönen abend noch